[Music]
Ruska is a remote village in southern
hungary right on the border with serbia
this barbed-wire fence is four metres
high and razor-sharp this is also the EU
s external border and it's now closed to
refugees kotti boo coach is visiting the
restricted access area in southern
hungry she was here in 2015 when the
first big wave of refugees arrived from
Syria Africa and Afghanistan I remember
these hordes of refugees on the border
in 2015 in Budapest we heard about the
conflicts and problems arising here we
brought hundreds of tents and blankets
with donations it was September and the
nights were already very cold it wasn't
easy to get past the armed guards
protecting the border kotti helped the
refugees put up tents their feet were
wrecked from walking long distances she
recalls and no provisions had been made
for them 30 years ago at Hungary's
border with Austria the world witnessed
another wave of refugees we saw
reporters applauding and here we are we
can't believe it it was in the border
town of Sharan that the Iron Curtain
began to crumble when 500 East Germans
fled to the west
Arpad Bela was one of the soldiers
guarding the crossing on the 19th of
August 1989 a peace demonstration was
being held what's going down in history
as the pan-european picnic Hungary
opened the border fence for three hours
in a symbolic gesture agreed to by
Austria and Hungary suddenly droves of
East Germans appeared in the corn fields
and fled across the open border it was
an escape that had been carefully
planned the border guards could have
prevented the escape it happened very
fast
the people only had to run 120 meters
and they did it in 20 seconds we had to
make a decision in that short time
les I wrote that article I don't
annually metallic he's been called a
hero ha that's only half true I don't
feel like a hero
not in the least but it's true that we
turned a blind eye we made sure we were
looking towards Austria and didn't see
what was happening behind us the East
German refugees were dazed but delighted
by empires were free we're glad to have
made it I can't really believe I'm here
I got off the bus just had a shop run
and crossed over
the escape had been made possible by
McLeish Nimet in 1988
he'd been appointed Hungary's prime
minister he decided it was no longer
necessary to secure the border with
Austria Hungary was close to an abyss
Hungary was bankrupt that time I am
sitting in my room not leisurely working
at UK you can see always come in the
budget for 1989 he came across a line
item identified with a secret code so I
immediately picked up my phone and
called up the interior minister and he
told me that this is the sum for the
refurbishment for the renewal of the
fence between Hungary and Austria and
what did he do then then I deleted
across that big sum out of the drop
budget the first hole in the Iron
Curtain the news spread around the world
on a tour today
hungry began dismantling the border with
Austria which has been in place for 40
years electric signals were taken down
along a stretch of the fence and barbed
wire was torn down all of them noted
what was going on and no knocking on my
door of the so den time Soviet
ambassador to Budapest protesting what
what you doing no telephone call from
Moscow it was planned for 20-25 minutes
and finally ended after two and a half
hours in a phone call Soviet leader
Mikhail Gorbachev pledged his support
until I am sitting in this chair there
will be no repetition of 56 which is in
other words was a clear-cut message that
my close
your hands are not tied up anymore
now hungry has rebuilt its fences to
keep refugees out the right-wing
government is anti-immigration to the
dismay of caribou coach nominee lemming
I wonder how many people these days
would be happy to see the Iron Curtain
that stood here 30 years ago many
Hungarians have the same opinion as the
owner of this ice cream parlor we had no
idea what was going on we didn't know
who they where more and more of them
kept on coming we were afraid many for
children we didn't know what these
refugees wanted this time we'll talk
with ironically now that the border is
closed business has dried up the ice
cream parlor is closing this year